en revanche jean luc bonjour ce n'est
pas là alors aujourd'hui on va voir une
émission particulière sur les sacrifices
spectaculaire et notamment et sacrifice
de plusieurs pièces tour à quoi voilà
tout à fait donc là j'ai fait une petite
sélection de partis historiques de
parties très célèbres ou le camp qui
gagne sacrifices
on va dire entre guillemets toute la
baraque il envoie tout plaisir pour
mater le roi de perse donc là c'est
simplement pour montrer que quand on
sacrifie beaucoup de matériel aux échecs
ça arrive je dire mais c'est vraiment
qu'on a vraiment des intentions
belliqueuses plus que le réel on va dire
mais puisque donc on va voir
quelques exemples aujourd'hui comme ça
de ces sacrifices donc ça fait
travailler la tactique ça fait
travailler la réflexion bon les échecs
évidemment c'est toujours travailler la
réflexion on a loupé ans ici la tactique
donc les combinaisons très important
parce que quand on a pris un avantage
positionnelle si on le transforme pas au
moment où il tout est transformé et bien
du coup mais on gagne pas l'avantagé
après tout tout tout la situation peut
se retrouver retourner oui un 16h07 le
jeu d'échec c'est quand même un jeu où
il faut être vigilant à chaque instant
donc là c'est clair qu'en montrant des
sacrifices un peu fantastique on montre
que quand même
quelquefois il ya une part de calcul et
de présence sur l'échiquier qui est bon
pour l'importante alors voyons tout de
suite cette première position
une position entre capablanca le fameux
a décidément très très très présents
dans ces émissions car un joueur wind
est considéré comme un échangeur mais
finalement ou une aussi très
compatissant samantha c'est un joueur
capable en plein et tu te disais je
crois qu'il ya eu une phrase célèbre qui
disait que là où je sais plus quel
joueur de son époque joue un langage
bien à prix capables un clash joue sa
langue naturelle exact je vais
naturellement aux échecs il avait
rejoint très intuitif et très intuitif
appris très jeune roi très jeune pardon
à 4 ans et avec une grande aisance
naturelle dans le jeu qui était connu un
plus pour un train un playboy des années
voire des années mais bien courir les
femmes etc
donc c'était un instinct aussi un bon
vivant voilà est qui qui ce qui ne
l'empêchait pas d'être d'être un joueur
d'échecs tout à fait extraordinaire le
champion du monde donc
elle a donc capable en cas qu'il fait
quand même qu'ils jouent cette partie la
partie qu'on va voir en simultané jeu
très importante aussi un simultané donc
sa place à brian joueurs et donc face à
un grand public
déjà on vieillit pas même le sens du
spectacle comme à l'époque déjà un mort
a tout de suite donc la combinaison dans
la position
on constate que le roi noir est un petit
peu n'est pas très bien protégé puisque
le son rauque et un peu dégarni on va
dire et en plus face à lui il a quand
même déjà
trois pièces et éventuellement une tour
qui est prête à intervenir pour l'action
voit on voit quand même lorsque alors
que lui pose des fourmis là uniquement
ça le d300s qu'on est surtout c'est le
luxe et que le roc noir est complètement
inexistant c'est à dire que là où on
voit que le roi blanc lui qui vont être
bien protégé derrière d'ailleurs celle
de pions lassé de ces deux fantassins
bien posté pour empêcher les échecs lui
seurinois on voit que quand même il y
avait un gros trou et utilise pour cette
colonne
il manque un pion est ce qui fait que
c'est une position très très délicate
très très faible ou les sacrifices
peuvent peuvent surgir
voilà tout à fait donc là on va passer
au sacrifice on va voir le coup le coc
spectaculaire qui a été joué dans cette
position donc le sacrifice qui attache
dans la position c'est le coup tout
reprend et surprend qui ont un gros
sacrifice de tours alors là un gros
sacrifice et j'aurais envie de dire
aujourd'hui pascal sacrifice et la crise
qui fit ce qu'on peut qu'on peut ne pas
accepter et c'est hélas un sacrifice qui
démolit entièrement la position du roi
noir puisque maintenant il n'y a plus il
est dans le vide total tous assez vite
de pièces et ça rien pour le défendre le
pauvre tyrol porteront à part ce petit
pion il faudrait qu'il se réfugier dans
le coin à la limite mais là c'est
vraiment délicat parce qu'il a plus de
défenses un pion - en plus y'a des pions
doublé au centre ce parti fusée c'est
catastrophique pour qu'ils acceptent
cette tournée il a pris la tour le
joueur obligé par le voir ce qui se
passe il faut voir ce qui se passe donc
là forcément quand on sacrifie une pièce
c'est pour surtout le tour c'est parce
qu'on a vu quelque chose qu'ils vont
dire qu'ils augmentent et les
le jeu rapidement on a dégagé la colonne
f avec ce sacrifice de toute la colonne
est ouverte
donc forcément on va rajouter une pièce
en attaque c'est à dire la deuxième tour
la tour en f1 et chez coran et
maintenant les noirs ne peuvent pas
jouer ce coup puisque là il ya un matin
de tout simple ce serait de monter la
tour henri vii sur échec on voit la tour
qui est défendu par l'adam attaque le
roi mode classique
le roi n'a qu'une seule case c'est donc
la case à schwyz et le fameux boss
baiser de la mort voilà le baiser de la
main avec la dame
on a même pu faire avec la tow en
embrasse le roi lui et c'est un baiser
mortel
voilà le seimat donc
cette fois il faut il faut rendre du
matériel c'est ce que c'est ce qu'ont
fait les noirs sa position ils ont donné
le cavalier obligé c'est le seul coup à
parois g7 très bien donc là évidemment
les blancs prennent alors une rupture au
point du plan aussi peut-être
on aurait pu reprendre du tout mais
n'avait plus loin il a vu plus loin il
veut faire jouer ses pièces lourdes
qu'il veut faire jouer ses pièces
lourdes
j'entends par cas selon de la tour et la
dame voilà très bien donc face au roi
adverse
encore une fois le fameux roi adverse ne
peut pas aller sur cette case toujours
pour les mêmes raisons totalement mêmes
raisons cercle si le roi bien sûr la
case g7 la tour descend sur f 7 mois là
ça avec le fameux m'attend h7 tafer donc
voilà une shon raison simple donc le roi
doit venir dans cette position le droit
de venir sur la case sur sa seule case
possible à la case e set où aussi si
aussi souci réussissent mais on va voir
qu'après le coup des blancs qui est à
9,7
de toute façon le roi ça aurait été
pareil sur les départs aille se doit
venir sur la case des six blessés dans
les deux cas même s'il avait été aussi
s'il aurait on se serait retrouvé dans
cette position
exactement donc la dame et la tour c les
pièces lourdes qui vont charger le roi
adverse
maintenant donc le roi est parti à
l'aventuré
grâce à ce sacrifice comme de pièces
lourdes oui on voit quand même vu
l'intérêt de ce genre de sacrifices
c'est que ça crée un déséquilibre total
au niveau défensif
si l'adversaire donc là on continue à
s'acharner sur le roi ne faut pas lui
laisser faut pas laisser dans ce genre
d'opposition au noir le temps de
respirer parce qu'ils ont quand une tour
de plus ici se regroupent et qu'ils
arrivent à repousser la taxe est ou qui
vont venir
exactement qu'il faut bas il faut
vraiment avoir tout calculer et en
général les échecs les uns après les
autres pour aller jusqu'au bout il faut
tout voir et là donc on voit que les
pièces lourdes ont une action sur la 5e
et sur la sur la 6e et sur la septième
rangée après le coup de chaud qui fait
échec on peut c'est très fier la dame
évidemment on peut donner la dame mais
sans rentrer dans les explications la
dame est plus forte dans cette position
que les deux cas on va prendre le pion
central qui reste l'hexagone 5 et
ensuite on a quand même beaucoup de
pions au centre ça fait quand même ça
fait comme une grosse part une grosse
grosse avance ses pions qu'il suffit de
compter on explique toujours qu'une dame
c'est à peu près 9 points et que deux
tours c'est 10 points
oui donc là si on compte le nombre de
pions qui valent un point on arrive à un
total de 12 contre 10
ouais donc de 12 pour les blancs entre
10 pour les noirs donc ces avantages le
roi blanc est en sécurité et en plus il
ya une masse depuis au centre qui
menacent d'avancé donc c'est très
agréable pour les blancs mais le coût
principal dans cette vision ses droits
ses 5
il a dépeint lanka a joué un coup
incroyable c'est que ils auraient pu
éventuellement faire échec au roi oui
messieurs le roi vient là et tenter
quelque chose autour du roi des nuits
mais il a joué un coup
pas direct il a joué à coude attente on
va dire il a joué dame prend la province
est choquant qu il a fait des échecs
jusqu'à présent là tout simplement il
fait plus d'échec il ya deux menaces
mais il ya deux menaces principales très
très dangereuse donc la première menace
que je vois tout de suite
jean luc ces dames b4 échec donc dam des
quatre échecs et mat donc on va mettre
ici c'est plus qu'un ex échec et madame
ici aussi la dame qui est sur la case 17
venait sur la carte b4 protégé par le
pion évidemment protégée par l'union c3
il protègera 7 15 le roi en soit 4 c 5
il ya plus de cases et le tri de gaz
la casse et 6,6 prise tout à fait donc
donc là il ya toutes ces menaces
et puis la deuxième menace donc voila un
petit peu la deuxième menace avec des
cartes c'est aussi tout reprend donc ses
six échecs et mat également échec et mat
également donc le roi peut pas fuir
quand on a qu'une seule défense n'y a
qu'une seule défense
c'est dingue des six pour protéger à la
fois de dingue des quatre est à la fois
deux tours processus exactement d'un v6
ça à cookies et qui a un usage qu on
dira qu'il ya deux usages donc deux
utilités et en même temps on voit que
sur un coup comme dame ici qui fait
chaque oui on aurait secoué et secoue
fait quoi ce qu on fait quoi ce pouf et
c'était ce que fait ce qu'est ce que tu
veux dire par là raconte pataquès qui se
passe ça c'est un truc que c'est une
question que je faisais mais peut-être
que le mois ses chars peut-être que le
roi mieux que ça arrive à se cacher ya
échec il ya échec voire très très bien
et richesse c'est un échec elle a
découvert ils ont à dire que la dame
attaque
le roi albert sorel échec et après les
noirs vont pouvoir se regrouper tout
simplement
voilà donc il faut toujours faut éviter
ce genre de choses faut vraiment tout
calculé tout calculé parce qu'un petit
échec et bouffe on a perdu du temps
ensuite les noirs se regroupent
oui les chèques la médiation l'échec un
échec à la découverte par le roi s'est
passé pas très courant c'est pas très
courant mais ça arrive souvent dans une
position puisque le roi
il n'arrête pas de bouger le roi fui
quoi que génèrent ces petits déchets
pour n'oublier qui fait mal quoi donc on
revient à la position la position finale
donc de cette superbe partie et l'a donc
le coup spectaculaire qu'à jouer notre
chance au niveau notre champion du monde
cubain donc un coup incroyable
il a donné une tour et là il décide de
donner une 2ème tour donc c'est vraiment
c'est quand même une partie qui fait
penser ou partie du siècle dernier donc
les parties qu'on appelait des parties
romantique
oui où les joueurs sacrifié beaucoup de
pièces pour mater le roi de perse et là
on reste dans la tradition on donne le
tour sur la case ces six échecs
ouais donc la tour attaque le roi en c5
il ne peut pas fuir il n'a pas de casse
de fuite s'il peut venir en plissant
qu'éventuellement le roi peut venir sur
la case des cinglés la dame est perdu
mais on perd la dame est encore une fois
la dame est plus forte que les deux
tours dans cette position l'actif de
position donc on est encore obligé de
prendre la tour avec la dame est là donc
le cubain a tout vu avait blessé le même
match comme on dit tout à l'heure sauf
que la place de 1,6 à la place du pian
il ya la dame voilà on a tout simplement
on a simplement construire un
raisonnement donc c'est très utile de
bien voir donc on va montrer le mat
d'abord donc on fait damer chaque dame
échec et le roi ne peut pas fuir toutes
les cases sont contrôlés toutes les
classes de fuite sans contrôler la dame
n'est pas prenable
et donc ce matin qui fait quand même
c'est vrai qu'il fait penser au match on
a démontré tout à l'heure c'est à dire
juste avant voilà voilà la menace qu'ils
avaient imaginé dans cette présence on
la voit là on aurait amat qui est quand
même assez identiques ou similaires qui
est similaire sauf que ces six quelques
pions et en plus il y avait la peau et
donc que de toute façon mais c'est vrai
que c'est très joli il fallait le voir
voilà donc ça c'est un sacrifice qu'on
pourrait dire c'est un sacrifice qui est
fait pour sortir le roi de sa tanière
oui voilà donc dans l'exemple qui suit
donc dans les amplis celui-là on aura un
sacrifice qui est plutôt pour étouffer
un petit peu le roi chez lui on va dire
on va on va donc donner la tour dans
cette position alors placé un petit peu
plus compliqué c'est que zone la tour en
donne à tours s'est pas forcé de
l'apprendre mais les menaces il ya une
menace et c'est très difficile de
défendre puisque là on voit que ces deux
tours et le fou dans cette position
attaque le pion oui ce qui veut dire que
ces trois pièces sont immobilisés sans
immobiliser pour défendre ce pion vols
et aux prochaines cours va jouer sans
doute aujourd'hui que peut être tout
reprend h5 avec échec donc tout reproche
une idée intéressante mais donc raison
plus pour origine un coût des noirs par
exemple alors après tout reproche 5on
imaginons que les noirs jouent à un
coude et attentes comme tous les styles
7 on peut prendre ici éventuellement
pourrait prendre la vasque à l'appui on
prend semble forcée voilà dans ce cas là
d'autres pions prend et maintenant on
ramènerait la dame sans doute et donc on
pourrait oui on pourrait ramener la dame
sur la case
2 voilà océans et autres immortels voilà
avec des menaces donc sur le roi adverse
et des menaces vraiment très très très
dangereux de menaces mortelles que la
barbe l'on joue un coup de tours par
exemple on le joue ici par exemple et là
on fait dame échec est le roi des sens
et là il ya maintenant un coup oui parce
qu'elles font grâce au courage
voilà donc le pion qui peut le voir ça
aussi ouais encore des trucs à voir le
fou le le fond qui coule le pion donc le
pion sur agout comme tour g6 c'est un
pion qui ne peut pas prendre la source
et mat
donc ça c'était la petite combine on va
revenir à la position donc après avoir
donné 7 pour les noirs prennent cette
tour c'est ce qui nous intéresse c'est
par ce qui se passe quand on donne le
matériel et là il ya un sacrifice
toujours un sacrifice spectaculaire on
peut peut-être joué le coup d'un des
deux mais là on a trait c'est joli cause
qu'il faut voir peut-être pour le
sacrifice jean huss et que ça peut-être
qu'en fait si cette dame là qui en fait
contrôler une grande diagonale ici bon
qui postait un peu est bouchée par la
tour finalement voilà et en plus le roi
bombay contrôle pour l'instant les cases
de pénétration et si on voit cette idée
là on pourra dans l'idée du conditions
on peut avoir l'idée et en plus on va
quand même sortir un petit peu le roi de
sa tanière avec ce coup on joue le coup
tous réussissent échec donc là le roi ne
peut pas aller ici par cas comme tu
viens de le prendre 2
le constatez vous un baiser de la mort
voilà un baiser de la mort avec la dame
qui traverse la grande diagonale donc là
le roi en g8 qui est mat tout simplement
jolies maths on est obligé donc de
prendre les tours et l'a donc le roi
sort un petit peu l'abri du roi a été un
petit peu assez oui un petit peu leur
cas c'est légèrement une légère faille
s'est installée donc maintenant on va
profiter de la faille pour amener la
dame dont la dame qui fait un grand saut
pour se rapprocher du roi voilà il a plu
beaucoup n'y a pas beaucoup de casse
sont loin et on n'a qu'une seule
il a que la gaz g6 tafer et l'a donc le
maté force et maintenant donc les blancs
ont joué le coup mais qu'en plus c'est
ça voilà c'est ma tante trois coups il
faut continuer à attaquer droit mais là
c'est un petit peu tactique donc on va
jusqu'à mener ok on prend on prend on
prend au f5
le roi est obligé de prendre puisqu'il
n'a pas de gaz on voit que la dame
contrôler ces cases contrôler tout ça ce
pion la contrôler cette case là donc le
roi est obligé de prendre le pion en f5
et là on pourchasse le roi comme ça avec
la dame échec et là on va quand même
qu'on a autour de moi mais ces pièces
pour l'instant comme elles n'ont pas
comme les noirs dans pas l'initiative
elles sont elles jouent pas et sorges
elles sont plus même à la limite elle
bloque le roi pour ses chats elle
n'empêche de fuir mais puisqu'elle
n'empêche de fuir et les pièces blanches
contrôler toutes les bonnes toutes les
bonnes cases le fou comprendre ce à dire
que c'est important ce petit pion
facebook sans contrôle cette case là ce
petit peu encore entre cette case là
donc le roi n'a plus beaucoup de cases
il ya une seule canal avec une somme
c'est celle ci c'est celle ci puisque
celle ci est contrôlé par la dame bien
sûr donc le roi vient sur la case m6 et
là il ya un matin à coup un battant un
coup donc d'un g5
échec et mat voilà c'est un échec et mat
donc caciques comme celui un peu combien
de voix finalement puisque la dame fait
un échec et le roi est bloqué sur les
cases blanches ici parlais tout à
l'heure il était bloqué par un type ion
hélas il est bloqué par un fou et par
son propre opinion aussi d'ailleurs
au passage donc un joli tableau final
voilà et donc la dame elle contrôle les
cases noires et le fou complète avec les
case verte 4 rouges et case verte voilà
on a fait un beau match très beau match
très très beau match donc on en a sorti
le roi de son abri on va reprendre juste
pour vous montrer donc très jolie
cependant une tour très jolie qu il la
prend on en donne une deuxième
n'essayez ya plus d'abris de plus et on
peut amener la dame et la dame combiné
avec le fou va donc permettre de mater
le roi comme ça de cette façon à l'est
d'alger 5h à 4 et jolie alors on peut
s'arrêter là c'était le troisième
combinaison d'aujourd'hui pour nous
c'était donc la troisième ou la deuxième
la deuxième donc ça va certainement ça
va vite
alors on va passer maintenant à une
autre à une 3e 3e qui toujours sur le
thème donc toujours ses deux tours ces
deux tours donc il faut jouer la dame
finalement qui font qu'il faut qu'ils
changent de la dame et qui permettent de
deux combats d'hier d'en savoir plus sur
ce qu'on appelle des réseaux de maths ou
des créer des schémas de maths donc là
c'est avec une dame est un fou tout à
l'heure c'était juste avec une seule
dame donc dans le prochain on va voir
que là ça va être avec
on va peut-être passer à la suite alors
quoi en avant la position dans le
prochain donc on va voir que là ça va
être encore une fois avec une dame est
un fou d'accord alors j'en dis pas plus
donc là c'est encore une partie
classique on voit que le roi noir et
protégés encore une fois le roi noir est
protégé par ses pions mais les tours
donc les tours blanches elles sont quand
même sur face au roi adverse sur les
lignes adverses donc stéphane tu vois
bien que dans cette position il y a des
possibilités d'attac
oui et le sacrifice donc le superbe
sacrifice va permette de tout ouvrir sur
le roy on l'a cette fois on va pas
laisser faire sortir chez lui on va le
maté à la maison on va le maté à
domicile c'est comme un match de foot là
où on se déplace chez l'adversaire est à
domicile et le math d'accord alors
voyons ça donc on joue tout reprend g6
on donne tout on donne une première tout
mais on casse aussi de fait la défense
ici du pion 10.5 voilà où on voit que là
il ya du lourd et qui est un droit
derrière là il ya toutes les pièces
lourdes en actions il faut pas oublier
ce fou qui suggère joue sur la grande
île a toujours énorme puisqu'il bloc qui
va jusqu'aux fut donc il cru se font en
temps ce fonds est louée et en plus ils
contrôlent des cases l'entrée très
d'ailleurs très très proches durant ce
qui est important c'est que là on voit
bien qu'une pièce à distance un fou par
un peu contrôlée peut être très actif à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier donc ça
c'est quand même très important de
savoir que on n'est pas obligé de
rapprocher s'en fout de l'adversaire il
peut être très bien placé donc sera
casse b2 et contrôler toute la déco
n'est plus la différence entre les
pièces à longue portée comme les fous et
tout
avec les pièces à courte portée
essentiellement mais les pions et les
cavalières et cavaliers laurent et le
roi donc là on donne la tour là pour
prendre forcément et maintenant on prend
un pion comprend un pion et on est à
complètement comme on l'a dit on a
complètement dégagé la colonne la
colonie est à noter qu'en plus avec ce
four b2 ce qu'on doit avoir tout de
suite se fout mais d ici est bien c'est
que c'est tout là des modèles qui est
contrôlé en transparence à travers le
fou c'est même la classe dash 8 est
contrôlé et hong kong en cloud le fou le
fou gsm c'est à dire que le fouquet sur
la casse g7 ne peut pas venir en reste
puisqu'on se mettre en action metella
tournoi c'est la même chose ça serait on
apprendrait tout simplement voilà elle
défend rien du tout puisque elle n'est
pas protégée par le fou qui peut pas
bouger donc on apprend donc si on voit
là ils sont là souvent ça change pas le
problème oui parce que le fouet coûts et
donc là on va bouger le roi ça change
pas le problème on obtient de quoi qu'il
arrive cette position donc on ne va pas
donner la tour on va la garder
on va la garder on va placer le roi
directement sur la casse g8 on a une
tour de plus
donc vous ne passez au goût de jouer
c'est aux blancs de jouer mais là dans
cette position beaucoup de joueurs
beaucoup d'amateurs ne verrait pas le
coup sans faire attention et tout bien
sûr mais avec un petit effort de
concentration on voit quand même que le
roi encore une fois est dans une sorte
de petit couloir
s'il n'a pas beaucoup de place pour se
déplacer
donc là il colle aux faits ayant le
soudan est très fort voilà ce fameux
chou blanc
deux outils est très très fort donc là
pour pour mater avec la tour et la dame
il faut faire ce jusqu où un incroyable
tour à schwyz faut donner la deuxième
tour il faut donner la deuxième tour on
est obligé de prendre un peu pour
apprendre avec la le droit la tour est
défendue par la dame dont on doit
prendre avec le font bien sûr et là
maintenant ça y est c'est facile et l'a
donc le saloum est avec dame est fou on
prend le fou avec la dame est donc le
roi échec et mat donc la dame qui était
quand même défendue par le fou sur la
grande diagonale et seimat
on a sacrifié encore une fois deux tours
et on a maté le roi adverse latéraux
adverses qui peut pas s'échapper
évidemment sa propre tour le bloc sa
propre retour le blog ou très joli très
joli tableau de matt smith est superbe
avec comme fou ce genre de fou comme ça
braqués sur l'euro et nuit évidemment il
est toujours extrêmement puissant il
faut s'en méfier quand on est en défense
et s'en servir avec force quand on est
en attaque donc dans l'exemple suivant
donc on va remettre la position donc
dans l'exemple suivant là on va voir un
réseau un petit peu résonne bat un petit
peu différent mais c'est toujours le
même principe c'est que cette fois on va
mater avec une dame est un pion pas avec
un fou à ça va être un tout petit peu
différent donc on va regarder la
position donc dans la position encore
une fois qu'on constate qu'il ya toutes
les pièces lourdes qui sont face au roi
adverse ça fait beaucoup mais le trou si
on doit en contrepartie il ya quand même
les
de fou défend le fou qui défend donc
c'est quand même des ça défend un petit
peu le la structure de pure donc il va
falloir donc toutes dégagées quoi il va
falloir vraiment toutes éliminées
éliminé pour mater encore droite le roi
chez lui pour pousser quoi donc pour
faire ça on donne une tour ici de ce
côté c'est vraiment très sauvage les
échecs quelquefois on menace dame en
huit matches échec et mat
on peut pas prendre la tour devant t on
pas prendre la tour du pion puisque le
dire puisque il ya un clouage évidemment
juste ça il ya ici c'est pas possible à
cause du cloud âge avec la tour donc la
seule possibilité pour les noirs c'est
de prendre de prendre la tour du
cavalier ici pour éviter le mat
voilà donc on fait le coup alors on peut
on fait le coup et là on parle et on
redonne une tour en bonne forme mais on
n'a pas peur on n'a pas peur hélas
toujours pareil on menace matt donc ya
pas le choix c'est récurrent c'est
toujours la menace récurrente il a pas
le choix il est obligé de prendre
l'autoroute
donc je vous ai donné un indice tout à
l'heure je vais parler de maths avec le
tas des pions donc on imagine que la
dame s'est quand même
celle ci est le pion avec un petit
effort on va quand même penser que c'est
ce qu'ils ont dit oui il faut peut-être
précis parce que l'on imagine donc si je
joue tout de suite salaire salaire
gagnant de jouer le groupe m6 tout
simplement ici puisque là le match
semblait imparable
comment parer ce matin voilà donc l'idée
évidemment avec la damer le pion
c'est de construire à matha sur la case
g7 mais le problème c'est que si on
pousse le coin tout de suite les noirs
ont le temps de glisser un coup de
défense du ku'damm g3 qui contrôle dans
la cage la colonne gillet et de surcroît
donc la liesse gesca et là c'est plus
pareil parce qu'on a plus de matériel on
a donné ses deux bourreaux
les noirs vont maintenant déployer leurs
forces ça va être très difficile
exactement donc il faut glisser un tout
petit coup intermédiaire c'est le
ku'damm g5 à chaque échec
le roi doit bouger en a huit ou en
achète donc ça ne change rien puisque là
on peut pousser les pions maintenant il
ya plus d'un gîte rendent donc là on en
est à 5 ans menace maintenant g7 est le
seul coup qui pourrait parler la menace
seul coup qui perd là bas d'autres oui
le seul coup qui par ses tours j'ai vite
mais malheureusement dans ces cas là la
dame prend le pion rachou bien sûr h
sicile royan en fuite et ses matisse est
bat donc cela la tourelle défend mais de
l'autre côté alors enlève la casse de
suite du roy pointe ne pas peut pas
s'échapper il est bloqué par sa propre
retour ici il est bloqué par le pion m6
est ici évidemment c'est la dame qui
contrôle tout et qui fait math donc un
bel exemple donc pour ouvrir le roi
adverse donc c'est une belle
illustration des attaques bien menées
il faut conclure donc pour conclure le
dernier exemple donc le dernier exemple
alors un exemple on va peut-être pas
rentrer trop dans les détails parce
qu'il est assez compliqué on a une
position où les blancs vont de l'attak
parce qu'ils ont la colonne
la colonne h dans cette position oui
donc et en plus ils ont un fou sur la
grande diagonale
oui donc ça c'est important parce qu'il
peut qu'il peut contrôler la casse g8 ou
en tout cas si le roi aller sur les huit
de clouer ce cavalier aussi donc il est
très peu fait sans doute très important
dans cette position se feront donc on
prend avec le cavalier un coup simple
mais avec déjà un piège si on joue
cavalier prend il ya un piège c'est que
dans cette position on donne la tour sur
le roi incroyable mais le voit ne veut
pas fuir ici puisque c'est contrôlé par
le fou et si le roi prend la tour ont
fait dame échec
voilà il ya un mode du couloir et voilà
il ya un couloir on va donner le fou
d'abord vous montrer la loire la dame
prend donc le fan au pouvoir le grand
couloir
parce qu'il est pris ici le roi ne peut
pas s'échapper ni là ni l'aï la blague
ici damman lagat les pièces mort mais là
aussi il ya le fameux fonds contrôle
donc c'est le couloir
c'est un couloir latéral on doit encore
donner le fou non et la dame point fouet
ces schémas donc premier piège et donc
la combinaison finalement quand on a
joué cavalier prendre il a dû prendre
avec le fou pourquoi il prend là parce
que la dame était attaquée puisque on
revient de prendre
discovery la dame était attaquée donc il
prend avec le fou et l'a donc tout
reprend un sacrifice donne encore la
tour encore le premier sacrifice de tout
rompre avec le cavalier on accepte voilà
il y en a a donc un coup incroyable qui
a été joué quand même par le premier
champion du monde tout reprend h cet
échec d'accord donne la deuxième tour
roy prend d'amasha toriola la même
combine la gamme sur sept qui contrôle
très bien la colonne hc superbe se fout
qu'ils contrôlent donc les cases
blanches icade blanche on doit fuir bien
sûr le fou fait cher avec vous et avec
tarifaire maîtrisant pas encore mais
avec fou c'est les coucous plus précis
c'est plus précis car si le roi vient
sur la case à la colonne h c'est trop
dangereux
c'est matt hill puisque la le fou contre
cette case je fous l'autre fou contrôler
cette case là d'accord et la dame
comment dire la dame ici contrôler toute
la rangée n'accorde donc il n'y a plus
qu'à donner les pièces sur h et ça sera
d'accord très bien après faut ici on est
obligé de venir là avec le roi oui la
dame monte effet échec
encore une fois si on pousse le pion à
ses matchs amat c'est un peloton
simplement les cases blanches et d'un
contrôle et ont été contrôlés au tour du
roi ressasser contrôlée par le fou donc
cette case là et tout le reste par la
dame est et tout le reste est contrôlé
par lada classic s'affaisse de maths un
aspire à l'encontre du roi et donc dans
la partie peu après d'un match 4 il a
joué 3 5 pour essayer de fuir il n'y a
pas le choix c'est le seul coup il n'a
pas le choix on prend un cavalier leroy
revient l'été cheikh oui bien sûr et là
donc le roi qui est sorti de son camp
donc ce fait mater par un fantassin par
adam
maintenant que vous le maté par un
fantassin il n'aurait pu mais je crois
qu'ils avaient vraiment envie de faire
jouer sa d'arbres c'était le but
on aurait pu jouer ça c'est vrai mais il
admis mais les stylistes donc la simat à
jouer d'ahmed 4 il a joué d'un f4
il y avait de monde possible et c'est
matt donc le roi qu'il peut pas fuir
toujours les mêmes qu'à ce contrôle en
moi je préfère le mc du pied au fond ce
que j'aime bien que toutes les caisses
participantes
c'est une façon de récompenser le pire
on que quand il m'a
version je vis aujourd'hui donc on a vu
tous ces exemples double sacrifice de
constructif à méditer à travailler
évidemment avec ces exemples là il y en
a d'autres et qu'il faut c'est déplacé
dans ses propres parties évidemment
c'est plus difficile c'est beaucoup plus
mais de toute façon ça c'est quand même
des exemples qui permet d'être un peu
plus inspiré et avoir de se dire qu'on
peut quelquefois je joue avec du
matériel en moi si on est malin pas si
on a des idées originales fait mal